[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director here at long now and
as many of you know we do what's called
a long short at the beginning of several
of these talks Andrew on our staff this
beautiful piece that was edited together
by Chris Abbas with imagery from the
Cassini mission which you're gonna be
hearing a lot about tonight this one
just as a warning has a lot of flashy
black-and-white things if that bothers
you fear your eyes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
where is home the question gets
different answers depending sort of when
you ask and the timeframe they ask you
it's only in the last 50 or 60 years
that we got used to thinking of home as
Earth and maybe over the next hundred or
so years that could jump out another
scale to where we would talk about the
solar system the whole set of stuff
going around the Sun our star and we'll
find out things like are we the only
life yeah this particular star system a
person who is looking into that who is
totally at home in the solar system is
careful Varco well thank you Stuart
and thanks to the long now foundation
for the invitation to come to speak to
you tonight and thank you all for being
here and just by way of managing
expectations you do know that no one
really knows how to search for life
don't you or at least people think they
know but no one agrees to the best way
to do it so nonetheless I'm gonna make a
valiant effort to describe where we are
with this issue in the opening decades
of the 21st century and the very
question is there life like me elsewhere
in the universe which naturally follows
from contemplation of your own existence
has to be one of the most beguiling
questions
has ever arisen in the human mind it
might even be the oldest and it
certainly is a question that has
transfixed us down through the ages you
could say I think that the attribution
of events to spirits and gods represent
the earliest human thoughts about
extraterrestrial life but at least in
the historical record speculations about
the existence of other inhabited
earth-like worlds first appear in the
writings of the ancient Greeks
and here from the Greek school of
atomism in the 4th century BC to
consider the earth is the only populated
world in infinite space is as absurd as
to assert that in an entire field sewn
with millet only one grain will grow
they were onto something those Greeks
the darlings of the ancient world but
many centuries later in the Middle Ages
Christian scholars who had finally
gained access to the writings of
antiquity speculated on the plurality of
worlds and suggested in fact that such
worlds just might be inhabited by
intelligent beings on a par with humans
but in every age such assertions met
with were vigorously challenged and and
debated around the time of the American
and French Revolutions there were great
intellectual debates about life the
nature of life the reason for life and
the possibility of life elsewhere and by
the time of the late 19th century
science fiction writers were getting
into the act and creating the idea that
the planets in our solar system were
teeming with life and by the middle of
the 20th century
with the advent of the Space Age and the
robotic exploration of the planets as
well as the availability of giant
telescopes on the ground that could
survey the skies and with the
opportunities that these developments
presented for cyan't do scientific
investigations of extraterrestrial
bodies the answer to this question was
finally Within Reach
and searches for alien life both
microbial and intelligent finally began
in earnest and they continued to this
day
in particular the possibility of
actually studying a closed hand the
planetary environments across the solar
system was not lost on those who wrote
the charter of the newly formed National
Aeronautics and Space Administration and
if you examine the literature
documentary documenting the history of
the civilian space program you will find
statements such as that made by the
first NASA deputy administrator and
aeronautical scientist Hugh Dryden - in
a letter that he wrote to the National
Academy of Sciences dated October 20th
1959 he offered his own suggestions
about what NASA could do in studying the
earth studying the cosmos and examining
you know the nature of the cosmos and
also the planets around the Sun but his
suggestions included this another and
very exciting philosophical basis for a
space program might be to seek out
extraterrestrial life the philosophical
implications of such a discovery are
tremendous and surely of interest to the
entire world as well as to the scientist
so nearly 40 years later with the Cold
War that initially drove us into space
to begin with finally over
NASA was seeking renewed justification
for the continuation of its space
program and in 1996 it laid out three
basic questions to guide the next
exploration era and they are how did the
universe come to be what is the origin
of life and his life unique to the earth
obviously the questions of our origins
and the existence of life elsewhere are
as enthralling to us today as they were
millennia ago and that's for very good
reason because to begin with there is an
enormous advantage in being able to
compare the biochemical underpinnings of
any extraterrestrial organism with that
of Earth and in this in the same way
that we
have gained by studying more than just
our own planet we've gained an
understanding of the processes involved
in in planetary formation and origin and
development of planets and so on
hmm so there's a lot of intellect
there's a lot of science to be gained
from comparing should we ever find a
second Genesis that is a completely
independent origin of life that has no
connection to life originating on the
earth and then should we ever find
terrestrial life that we could be
confident was a second Genesis that
would tell us immediately that life was
commonplace that it was not a bug but a
feature of the universe in which we live
and probably had occurred a staggering
number of times across the 13.8 billion
year history of the cosmos and besides
wanting to know if it's just us or is
life commonplace throughout the cosmos
speaks to our desire to put our cosmic
circumstances into perspective stuck as
we are on some insignificant little mote
of dust around an ordinary star in an
ordinary galaxy among hundreds of
billions of galaxies and more it speaks
to our longing to grasp the meaning and
the significance of our own existence
now you all certainly will appreciate
the possibility of life elsewhere and
especially intelligent life has been
historically and still is a very
sensitive topic Charles Darwin himself
was very worried about publishing his
Origin of Species because he was worried
about the Fleck that he was going to get
from the Church of England and that in
fact happened they gave him a lot of
Fleck and if you work with NASA the way
I do you become acutely aware that there
are people all over the globe who expect
great and almost mythical things from
this agency and so we go about this
business very mindful of this and
prepared maybe braced for the day when
should we ever find life elsewhere NASA
may just incur the wrath of some not
insignificant segment of the population
well what we're prepared for it at least
I'm prepared for it and until that
happens we'll just keep we'll just keep
doing what we do now in order to search
for something it helps to know what
you're looking for and how to recognize
it and this gets to a very gnarly issue
in this whole business an issue that
many committees are very smart and
accomplished scientists have been called
together over the years by NASA by the
National Academy of Sciences to settle
to adjudicate and that is what is the
definition of life and I can tell you no
one individual and no committee has ever
been able to do it it turns out that
it's a kind of thing you know when you
see it but other than that it's very
hard to reduce life in quotes to a
simple description or a common set of
defining characteristics that cannot be
refuted by a single counter example
those terrestrial organisms that you and
I would describe is alive if they were
to walk across the stage or fly or
whatever are just too diverse to fit
under one definition mmm so this has
made the whole thing about what we
search for when we search for life
actually rather difficult nevertheless
at the most fundamental level the level
of chemical elements and molecules that
are required to make the organism all of
organisms on earth share that they're
all biochemically identical and this it
is this basic biochemical identity that
strongly suggests that all of life on
Earth arose from one single origin and
it is this biochemical identity that
makes it even possible to find if not a
definition of life at least some general
attributes of living systems that could
be useful in ascertaining first what
that origin of life was and it gives us
a place to start in searching elsewhere
for life so I'm gonna spend some time
here talking about those attributes of
life I didn't know if all of you have
just all boned up on your high school
biology but I mean I was assuming you're
like me and you hadn't done it for a
long time and so I'm just gonna tell you
the general attributes that anyone
preparing a talk I might put
okay okay the first is architecture what
is the architecture of life well life is
very modular - like Legos okay and it's
remarkable but a select and limited
number of small molecules that call
monomers but think of them as building
blocks they can't constitute the basic
architectural elements of all living
systems on earth and these monomers as
they develop they join together in
modular fashion to make longer and
larger molecules and guess what they're
called polymers get it mono/poly bristle
clever and as far as proteins go its
amino acids that are the building blocks
of proteins and these are linked
together to form the biopolymers called
proteins and proteins make up more than
a half of the dry mass of animals and
are multifunctional they are structural
they provide the scaffolding of living
organisms on muscles or hair and nails
cartilage tendons all of that is made of
proteins and proteins are also
functional in in metabolism they are
they serve the role of enzymes serving
to accelerate chemical reactions within
an organism there are over 200 amino
acids but all of life on Earth uses only
22 and we have to ingest nine of them
actually our body makes the rest so when
your mother used to tell you you better
eat your proteins she actually knew what
she was talking about proteins also are
the shape shifter molecules I forgot to
show you this but is this a pointer this
is a pointer so amino acids and they
make peptides along linear chains and
then they make proteins and proteins
they fold they're long they're gooey
they're they have almost no internal
structure but they can get very big and
they fold in complex ways then we get to
DNA which is a nucleic acid this is the
famous double helix and DNA is made out
of building blocks called nucleotides
and these
the information encoding molecules that
form two rungs of a line they form the
rungs of a ladder and you prot in well
let me before I get that if you want
coil the DNA molecule you get something
that looks like a ladder this is really
challenging I need a lot of hands here
so here the the rungs of a ladder the
rails I guess they caught these are the
rungs excuse me these are the rails so
each rail is made out of a string of
sugars okay and then attached to that is
a phosphate group it's identical on
either side and it's the rungs and the
way they bond that form the yet the
attachment and they are the ones that
convey the information the arrangement
of them is in information encoding and
the success of DNA as the information
encoder from generation to generation
and so on is down to this periodic
structure and persistent structure its
form is not altered when you remove one
of the nucleobases and put in a
different one and it's not even its
physical and chemical properties are not
altered when you do that and if you if
those properties had altered it wouldn't
serve as that the molecule that serves
as the template Iser if you will so it's
very unlike proteins which as I said
well they can collapse when one of its
components one of their components are
altered and then we get to when we get
to know we're not there yet we get to
carbohydrates which are polymers made
out of sugars you know that that's what
makes us fat
you'd rather not know it I'd rather not
know it too but that's the truth and
carbohydrates a part of DNA as you saw
DNA consists of sugars and they are part
of cell membranes and they're also the
sources of energy and required for
metabolism and then they were the lipids
or the fatty acids they don't
technically form polymers but they
joined together - they don't dissolve in
water which is a critical feature and so
they are the compounds that make up our
cell walls okay
and this is obviously critical for
maintenance of your body so when the
food industry tells you to go on a
low-fat diet don't listen to them we
need fats they are essential good good I
guess that's someone who works for the
fat industry actually I could use this
moment to just rail against the sugar
industries the real the real culprit
here okay it's the carbohydrates who are
the enemies not defense okay anyway so
continuing we have biogenic elements and
intriguing and significant aspect of
terrestrial life architecture is that
the building blocks themselves are made
of only a few elements and you all
remember this yes you remember this this
is the periodic table out of the 90
elements that occur in nature life is
made predominantly vastly predominantly
of only a few carbon hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen phosphorus and sulfur 98% of
the mass of living organisms consists of
these elements other elements are
presents you have calcium in your bones
you need magnesium and potassium for
cellular function and so on but it's
only a few basic elements that are
important for life on Earth so earthly
life is selected a very small percentage
of all the available atoms to make its
basic collection of simple molecules and
utilizes only or makes only a small
fraction of all possible building blocks
out of them and this is another fact I
hope you see where I'm getting
another effect will come we'll return to
later when I talk about what it is we go
look for another interesting property in
architecture is core allottee and
chirality is the property that basically
refers to symmetry you have molecules
that are symmetric and these molecules
would look like they're mirror image so
HTA water h2o is one such molecules co2
is a symmetric molecule but there are
some molecules which are not symmetric
they would not look like they're mirror
images and think here we have this for
you okay but you can just look at your
hand okay imagine these are atoms and
this is a molecule okay these are all
the same as this but you have one atom
here you have one atom here they are
chemically identical but they have a
different handedness it's called
chirality okay and it turns out all
living organisms on earth utilize and
construct biopolymers of only one
handedness okay earthly life uses only
left-handed amino acids and right-handed
sugars and it cannot make use of the
other types of molecules because they
just don't fit it's just a geometry
problem they don't fit and if a
substance or some environment in a
natural world that contains no life but
has a predominance of one handedness in
its molecules over time processes will
happen to equalize it eventually you'll
get a mixture that's got 50% right 50%
left mmm so a preference for chiral
molecules and one handedness is a
feature of terrestrial organisms that
again we'll return to later and then a
final aspect of architecture are of
course cells cells separate a cell
separates itself from the environment
and regulates its communication with the
environment it's it's a way to form a
cocoon where it can maintain its own
environment like you want to
air-condition your house for example
that's what cells do cells are made out
of lipids the cell walls are made out of
lipids as I just said and
lipids would have been available in an
environment they readily form vesicles
just drop some oil into water and you
could see that for yourself so you can
imagine that sequestering in one place
for example nucleic acids and proteins
was a critical step in its step towards
life now another attribute of attribute
of life after we're discussing
architecture is representing
reproduction occurs because of a
cyclical feedback or feedback control
system in which information contained in
the genetic polymers is used to direct
the synthesis of catalytic polymers or
proteins and in turn those proteins are
used or take part in the synthesis of
the genetic polymers and during growth
this entire system reproduces itself but
reproduction is not perfect that's where
we get up to evolution and adaptability
through mutations reproduction is not
perfect because mistakes are made
they're called mutations and they result
in the organism having slightly
different characteristics and the vast
majority of mutations that occur are not
helpful they're not beneficial and so
the new organism dies or it doesn't live
long enough to reproduce and in that
sense the mutations are not successful
and they don't live and you don't see
them in the genome anymore but in rare
circumstances the new properties that
are conveyed to the organism by the
mutation mm allow the organism to
compete for nutrients and otherwise
adapt better to its environment and
those organisms live and they get to
reproduce they pass on their genetic
information and this is the process of
natural selection the fittest get to
survive and evolution occurs so this is
evolution working at the behest of
natural selection and then another
attribute is metabolism this is the
property of them the organism has to
exchange materials with its environment
for its energy needs for example and it
involves the breakdown of materials
conversion of the products to energy and
the attendant construction of materials
it needs to live and also the
elimination of waste materials earthly
life employs a chemical metabolic
process
that is physically contained within a
cell and then there's the presence of a
solvent I should have said something
about energy sources where that comes
next so I got this out of order so
solvent the chemistry underlying but
biology on earth is a solvent is the
solvent liquid water and water is a
polar molecule so it can dissolve easily
can dissolve substances it's why it's
used for washing you could even wash to
some degree without soap because of the
polar nature of water and it provides a
handy way for complex molecules to be
broken down into smaller components
because of that at the debt aspect of it
it can also turn elements into ions you
can dissolve sodium chloride in it you
get sodium ions chloride ions and those
are needed for cellular function but it
also serves as a medium within which
chemical reactions can take place more
readily materials can diffuse around in
it they can meet up with each other more
easily than if one substance was sitting
on a rock and another one was sitting on
top of another rock and they were
waiting for a wind to come along and
that's not so easy but water makes
mingling you know dating and mating
makes it possible and then energy
sources mmm for earthly life there are
two main sources of free energy one of
course is sunlight and organisms have
evolved to make direct use of sunlight
but there's also chemical energy and and
this is you don't utilize sunlight at
all all the energy is chemical and we
found in the 1970s entire Ecology's new
Ecology's on the earth some literally
living miles underground and some
thriving in hellish conditions around
exceedingly hot hydrothermal vents at
the bottom of the ocean and these
organisms were living off minerals and
other chemical compounds that were
emerging from the sea floor and hot
fluids and the biological cycles that
underlie these ecologies are basically
an exploitation of thermodynamically
favorable chemical pathways that already
existed in the environment in the
organisms
to them and when I say chemical pathways
favorable chemical pathways I mean
pathways they're not energy neutral and
they're not energy consumptive but
they're energy rich so the organism can
can derive energy from from adapting to
it so these are the main features of
earthly life that we can you know get
our heads around
they don't constitute the components of
a strict all-encompassing definition but
as a collection they paint broad a broad
picture of what life on Earth is all
about and they help us they give us
guidelines in what we might look for in
in searching for life now in the
planetary exploration program the
practical goal from the start way back
in the beginning was to determine the
physical chemical properties of all the
accessible bodies in the solar system
and then single out those places that
that have what has come to be called
habitable zones those locales that meet
the basic requirements for supporting
and maybe even initiating
extraterrestrial life and because we are
a long way from understanding how alien
life might present itself that is life
with an entirely different biochemistry
outside of a few basic Universal
properties that are based more in
physics than on chemistry like
disequilibrium that's a main physical
property that has to be there in an
environment or life does not does not
sustain itself aside from from that nASA
has been focused on the search for life
as we know it okay because that's what
we know how to recognize it's in our
present state of ignorance it's not an
unwise course of action though I think
we'd all agree the most interesting type
of life to find would be life that was
completely different than life as we
know it it would allow us as I said
earlier that opportunity to contrast and
compare and find out what's necessary
for the origin of life and what was
contingent so for some time now the
mantra at NASA has been follow the water
because if you've just seen as you've
just seen it is the solvent for
terrestrial life by the way this
issue the issue of looking for alien
life though difficult is not going on
addressed we don't we don't make a big
deal of it it's not our main thrust of
activity in planning missions to the
planets but there are places where
people are trying to grapple with what
alien life might be like there is work
being done for example by organic
chemists in laboratories where they're
attempting to reproduce some of the
processes involved in life's chemical
machinery by using molecules that are
different than those used by earthly
life such as encouraging the creation of
molecules that can carry genetic
information that are not DNA actually
trying to create synthetic biology and
also in the last 40 years or so there
have been efforts to try to understand
the process of the evolution of living
systems in terms of growing levels of
complexity and this is the kind of
examination that you can actually do on
a computer and this I happen to find
most fascinating this is an area where
the general attributes of living systems
and even nonliving physical systems can
be reproduced at least in the abstract
on a computer by beginning with very
very simple initial conditions and
following very simple rules for the
evolution of the system and I'm going to
show you some examples and what I'm
referring to and they come from a book
written by the main developer in this
area of work Stefan Wolfram you voted in
2002 he's also incidentally the guy who
invented the MATV computer language
Mathematica okay so he's a formidable
guy and he just started with something
very simple imagine a graph paper with a
grid and on one row you put a black
you've color in a black square and then
you ask okay I want to move from that
square down to the next row of now blank
squares and I just want to employ simple
rules for how I colorize the squares in
the row below the first one and I'm just
gonna use nearest neighbor rules I'm
gonna say well the one below the black
is going to be well this is in a two
color black or white system
is going to be black if the neighbor to
the left is white and the neighbor to
the right is white but it's going to be
white if the neighbor to the left is
white but the neighbor to the right is
black and those kinds of things so he's
got a set of rules of what happens in
the road below and then he started out
in the beginning with very very simple
rules and it's astonishing what happens
as he just goes down and down and down
and creates patterns so here is his rule
number 30 in his book a new kind of
science I think that's what it's called
this is a what he's called a two color
cellular automaton and it exhibits both
organized and random structures as you
can see and you get it starts out with
an asymmetric rule but you could see
very organized structure on the left and
random structure on the right okay and
then he adds three colors he allows for
gray and this is a three color example
and it's 9000 steps and each column is
3,000 steps and you can see just gets
these very ornate in fact almost
artistic patterns and it continues and
it continues and then it suddenly stops
out of nowhere no one told it to do
anything it's just it's just following
these simple rules and then it ends up
with these simple repetitive patterns
that just keep going they're stable they
don't change and they just keep going so
the point here is that the growing
complexity that we see in the evolution
of life on Earth and peaking in the
highest forms of life if I may say so in
particular with an organism that can
reflect on the means by which it came
into existence may be nothing more than
the natural outcome of the mechanism
Darwinian evolution working at the
modular and molecular level but working
with the building blocks of terrestrial
life the few biopolymers and following
simple rules that instruct the chemical
system how to go from one generation to
another for billions of years and this
fascinates me because what really is the
most fascinating thing about my
is how complex have finely-tuned it is
how sophisticated it is and of course
you might think it was created by a
divine being but it doesn't necessarily
have to be you can get complex patterns
on a computer with very simple rules I
might mention more of these items later
mmm okay so when it comes to looking for
life in the solar system the most
straightforward thing we can do and it's
actually not that straightforward is to
seek habitats that would resemble those
on earth and could support life as we
know it while also being alert and
mindful of the possibility that we might
confront an alien type of life wherever
we go so what are the factors so that
means a search for life as NASA
manifests it is a search for habitats
and hmm what are the factors to consider
in our search you know in our search
besides looking for those places that
have liquid water okay so I said liquid
water already but we also there's
organic so we just said life on Earth is
made of organic materials they are
simple there's a handful of elements
that go into organic materials if we're
searching for life that might be bio
chemically similar to us it makes sense
to search for those particular elements
and molecules other considerations or
energy sources
okay bio usable energy or sunlight and
Kemba chemical energy I just mentioned
that mmm
energy is needed to maintain
disequilibrium so if we go to a place
and we find there's no free energy
available it wouldn't be a good a good
choice to to search for for life and
then there's another issue of longevity
if you want to talk about the origin of
life then we need to find those places
where the ingredients that I just
mentioned and the habitable and nature
of the environment has been around long
enough for life to get started
unfortunately we don't know how long it
took life to get started
it surely occurred I mean it surely
occurred on earth we think it occurred
somewhere between the time that the
surface of the earth became quiescent
enough F
it's a chrétien of material from the
solar nebula after it had four millions
hundreds of millions of years had
material raining down on it while it was
growing but at some time that tailed off
so at some point it became quiescent to
have bodies of water on it that weren't
boiled away with the next impact and
between that period of time and then we
know when the first fossils appeared the
first fossils that we're confident of or
at least the most famous ones I'm sure
there is somebody out there who knows
more about this than I do but 3.8
billion years ago is the date of the
oldest fossils stromatolites these are
pillows these are organisms or
communities of organisms something like
coral that used to live in shallow seas
and right now the most famous fossils
are in Western Australia so in the
interval between when we think the earth
became quiescent although that is being
hotly debated now so I even hesitate to
give you a number but between that time
and the time of the first fossils is
when we think life arose on earth hmm
unfortunately like I said we don't know
very much about when that happened but
in looking for habitable zones that this
criterion is actually treated quite
seriously a small body of water on the
surface of a planet like Mars let's say
that was created by an impacting comet
and therefore wouldn't last very long
because eventually even though it might
be very voluminous eventually over time
it would evaporate we wouldn't consider
that as being a place viable for the
origin of life we'd have to have water
that's stuck around for a while and then
other considerations life different from
earthly life instead of water some
possibilities instead of water as the
solvent maybe there could be another
liquid that is the solvent and then
another Universal feature of the genetic
molecule it has been argued and paper
has just come out in astrobiology
journal describing this another feature
of the genetic molecule that actually
gives it its persistent shape is the
fact that the fuss
vade group that I pointed out to you
these things are actually charged and
they have similar charges so they
actually repel each other
now the bonds holding the molecule
together are strong enough to overcome
this but the fact that they they repel
each other actually stretches out the
molecule and in some sense keeps it
rigid and and allows it to form its
template in templating function but the
suggestion has been made that any
Universal that any genetic polymer do
even irrespective of the underlying
biochemistry should function in this way
if it has a molecule that is passing on
genetic information that must be a
feature of it that would apply in any
biochemistry so maybe we should go
looking for that just carry an
instrument that could go sample some
water in some environment and just check
to see are any of these types of
molecules they call polyelectrolytes are
any of them there so people are thinking
about how to search for life that might
not be like ours and then there's the
practicality always of acquiring samples
at NASA it is a hard and cold fact for
us we can dream about all the wonderful
things we'd like to do but when the
rubber meets the road we got to put an
instrument on a spacecraft we're going
to launch it way the hell away from here
we're not going to bring it back into
the shop if something goes wrong we got
to know what we're doing and so there's
hard and fast practicalities one of them
in this business is you have to acquire
a sample so you have to go to the places
where it's easiest to to get a hold of a
sample of the environment that you could
you could test how easy is it to access
the habitable zone you want to study so
after all of that what environments are
we considering now in 2017 after we've
spent 60 years exploring the solar
system and the last 27 exploring the
satellite last 13 exploring the Saturn
system clearly in our solar system there
is only one body that fits the
old-fashioned habitable zone requirement
it used to be you'd look for the
distance from a star
which liquid water could exist on the
surface but that all changed in the
1970s when a large subsurface biosphere
on a planet was found and it was
bolstered once we began that idea that
you could have a biosphere underneath
the surface was bolstered when we began
exploring the outer solar system and it
started with Voyager in the 1980s when
it became clear that we could solve the
water requirement not on the surface but
underneath within bodies if the body
were undergoing strong enough tidal
forcing and then tidal flexing from its
parent body its host planet or
sufficient internal radioactivity to
melt the ice that the bodies in the
outer solar system are made of and
produced liquid water so this was a
paradigm shift that there could be
ecologies within bodies as well as on
the surface that greatly increased the
potential habitable zones in our solar
system so where are they there are there
are a handful of them across the solar
system I'm only going to mention the the
big four I hope I get through these in
the length of time I have you probably
know about them already they are
drumroll they are Mars Europa Titan and
Enceladus and these are worlds with past
or present liquids either on the surface
or with them so we start with Mars Mars
is the only the only planet right now
that has a sustained program of robotic
exploration that's devoted to it it's
been clear for some time now so going
back to the 1970s that liquid water once
flowed on the surface of Mars I don't
know maybe only the older people in the
audience remember Viking landing on the
surface of Mars in 1976 it's it irks me
to no end when people young people think
the first time we ever landed on Mars
was in 1997 with what a pathfinder or
with the Mars exploration Rovers we did
this back in 1976 before you were born
okay and we found that water once flowed
on Mars not by chemically this is this
we didn't Rove so there wasn't a lot of
chemical stuff going on but we could see
in the images you could see here
features that obviously look like they
were created by a flowing liquid and the
only possibility the only plausible
possibility was water and so now we
think that there was a time probably a
billion years ago when it was warmer
warmer and Mars had had substantial
liquid water but the liquid water now
for the most part seems to be all gone
at least from the surface Mars is
presently in its ice ages and so a more
appropriate guideline for Mars might be
follow the ice and not follow the water
and we know there's lots of it on Mars
it's mixed in with the soil it's at high
mid latitudes and poleward but what
about organics organics have to be there
if we're talking about our kind of life
but the surface conditions are ma on
Mars a very toxic to organic materials
they're easily destroyed by ultraviolet
radiation and there's oxygen in the
atmosphere that oxidizes them so it
destroys the organics so if there are
lots of organics on the surface then it
means two things it means either they're
organic materials that were delivered on
the backs of meteorites meteorites have
organic materials they have amino acids
in them and things like that hmm
but organic-rich meteorites only have
about 30% of organics by mass so if oh
end the other possibility is that you
had vigorous biological activity that
was creating organics those are the only
two possibilities but if you find a lot
of organics you might assume it was the
result of present-day
activity because the meteoritic material
is not a is only like I said a few
percent did I say 30 percent I meant to
say three percent by mass so at the
moment we have on the surface the
Curiosity rover and it's
the surface in Gale Crater it's making
lots of measurements of the surface but
a sad truth about this mission is the
following that before curiosity even got
to Mars and after the mission was all
design instruments were decided designed
built and so on another mission at Mars
called Phoenix found a salt culprit
chlorate on the surface of Mars that the
good news is it allows it suppresses the
freezing temperature of water and it
allows sporadic water to exist in I
don't know if you remember but there was
a observation of gullies on the surface
of Mars and these were watched during
the course of a Martian year and it was
found that they seasonally appeared and
disappeared and it was found that they
are really the result of water coming
out of the layers in the rock and
flowing down the surface so people got
very excited about this but then it was
remind people reminded of the
perchlorate on the surface perchlorate
is saltier than the saltiest environment
we have here on the earth the saltiest
environment on the earth at least that
anybody's found is a pond in Antarctica
called donjuan pond and I'm sorry I
don't remember the amount of salinity it
has but it is so saline that living
organisms can't live in it well
perchlorate is many times more saline
than that
so perchlorate on the surface of Mars
and it's distributed all over the place
means that if there's water on the
surface of Mars they can't possibly be
anything living in it so so what's
happened is now that the look people the
Martian community I think is turning to
the idea that not looking for extant or
living life they're looking for
fossilized life they're looking for the
environmental conditions that might have
been habitable to life in in ancient
times so they're looking for those
places where there's compelling evidence
of let's say ancient hydrothermal
Springs and looking for fossils it's not
too promising for biochemistry and also
one thing that's very unsatisfying about
Mars is that we know there's been a
healthy exchange of materials between
Mars and Earth
so you could never really know if you
found life on Mars if it was similar to
life on the earth if it represented a
second Genesis or not it might still be
earthly life so on to the next Europa
whoops
okay Europa is a moon of Jupiter it's
about the size of our moon and we
suggested first by Voyager and then
confirmed by Galileo to have a salty
ocean within it mmm and the geology on
the surface is very strongly suggestive
that water once if not at present came
close to the surface this looks like ice
floes that you might see on a frozen
lake so this was very tantalizing of
course the Galileo mission didn't have a
high-gain antenna to work with it didn't
open so there wasn't a lot of imaging
done we haven't covered the surface of
Europa like we've covered all the moons
in the Saturn system with the Cassini
mission so there's a lot we don't know
about the surface of Europa but a major
an issue about Europa that makes it
difficult is that it is bathed in an
intense magnetic environment and it is
has very high levels of radiation
beaming down on it and this radiation
destroys organic materials on its
surface an organic compound put on its
surface would last somewhere between
tens of hours to maybe if you're lucky a
few years and so it's just not the best
place to go in my opinion in the opinion
of a growing community of people to go
look for life it would be very difficult
that even kills the spacecraft that you
send their kills the electronics now one
optimistic and recent development has
been the discovery of sporadic plumes
and I'll say a lot about plumes at the
next body mm-hmm a plume of materials
seen above the surface of Europa at
least seen from the earth and it could
be plumes like those coming from
Saturn's moon Enceladus so the mission
the next mission going back to Europa
and there is one in fact there may be
two very expensive missions to go finish
the work of Galileo in
mapping the surface and doing what it
should have done bringing the level of
understanding of Europa up to the same
level we have of Enceladus at Saturn and
if there's a plume there will be
instruments that can measure the
composition of it so we'll see how we'll
see how that goes but then of course the
other results of the Cassini mission at
Saturn has two very special moons I'm
running at a time and they are Titan
which is Saturn's largest moon and until
Cassini got there was the largest single
expanse of unexplored terrain that we
had remaining in our solar system and
now we've explored it and we've covered
it and then of course Enceladus which is
a small icy moon 1/10 the size of Titan
and because Cassini has been blessed
with a perfectly running spacecraft and
almost I think all of its original
instruments have been operational for
over a decade we know a great deal about
both these places Titan is mmm about the
size of the u.s. it's enshrouded in a
haze made of organic material we've
known that for a very long time it has
an atmosphere that's like Earth's it's
largely molecular nitrogen like what's
in this room its surface pressure is 50%
greater than the pressure we have in
this room its thermal structure is
similar to our atmosphere it's just
different in some fundamental ways first
of all it's very cold it's about 300
degrees Fahrenheit below zero and its
atmosphere is suffused with as I said
organic compounds like methane and
ethane and propane and so on and those
compounds in fact they're broken up
especially methane by radiation
ultraviolet radiation and and they end
up forming haze the carbon is released
from the methane and the carbons form
these long structures and they form the
haze that completely enshrouds it's 200
kilometers thick global shroud haze and
we knew about of course this haze in
fact on Voyager we couldn't see down to
the surface because of the haze but we
equipped our cam
with special filters that allowed us to
see the surface and so this is one of
our images it's been processed somewhat
to bring out features you could see
around the edges it's very hazy because
we're still you have to look through a
long path length along the edges but you
could see the surface somewhat this is
one of our early images it was very hard
to make out but but we got global views
of Titan with our cameras and then also
Cassini carried a radar instrument and
the radar instrument did an even better
job because it had no trouble seeing
down to the surface and here's a radar
image of one of the dark areas in the
equatorial region of Saturn of Titan
like in that area here well this is what
that looks like it's covered with dunes
these are dunes made of fine-grained
organic materials they're about two
kilometers distant from one another
they're about a hundred meters high
their longitudinal dunes they're aligned
in the direction of the wind and that
tells you that the winds are
bi-directional they come from two
directions and obviously it has to be
dry enough in order to loft particles
and form dunes so in fact the dry
conditions were very puzzling because
theoretical models told from the results
of Voyager that we should find liquid
hydrocarbons on the surface and so this
was early in the mission we didn't see
anything and it was very odd but of
course we were there for a long time and
we got finally to see that the liquid
hydrocarbons were present but they had
gone to the poles and this is one of our
most recent images taken I think just a
few months ago showing this region at
the North Pole because it's spring now
in the northern hemisphere of Saturn and
these region this is these are large
bodies of liquid methane on the surface
of Titan dot and these are smaller lakes
this this let's see this here is one
body okay and if you took Titan and you
scaled it up to the size of the earth
that would be the size of the
Mediterranean and now I'm going to show
you a radar image of this guy over here
and that's this and you could see
channels leading down into this body of
fluid it looks like the coast of Maine
somebody you might want to go there
someday it's a beautiful example of a
liquid methane sea on the surface of
Titan
and it is now believed separate issue
it's now believed that Titan also has an
interior liquid water ocean but that is
not what makes it so compelling what
makes it so compelling are these seas of
liquid hydrocarbon and even though those
exist we it's hard to imagine Titan is
offering a good chance for Lert looking
for life as we know it but it's
certainly the go-to place in our solar
system to study organic materials native
organic materials Institute in their
native environment something we can't do
anymore on the earth because of the
oxygen has destroyed them all and it
would be a site that might offer
alternate chemistry's like maybe methane
instead of water as the matrix but that
seems a stretch at temperatures of 300
degrees below zero Fahrenheit chemical
reactions would proceed very slowly
so anyway I'm nearing the end and I
haven't told you the best part okay I'm
sorry Stuart but I got to do this so
anyway the best moon of all of course is
Enceladus this is not meant to be a
threat by the way I would never want to
show this to Donald Trump
but anyway so it's about the size of
England and it has four prominent
fractures crossing its South Pole you
can see here and you can see even better
here this is really challenging okay
there's three screens to thingamajigs so
anyway these are four fractures and this
hole this is the south polar terrain the
South Pole is about right there and this
is this region is circumscribed by a
chain a continuous chain of mountains
and folds and ridges and we found
there's no craters here that means it's
very young and we found when we put any
found
lot of heat coming out of this region
which is very puzzling because it is the
South Pole after all and we found when
we put ourselves in positional look over
the South Pole of Enceladus but in the
direction of the Sun which is a geometry
that highlights the presence of small
particles we saw plumes and and geysers
actually and here's a bunch of pictures
we took this is in 2005 that's when we
first saw that the plume we had
discovered earlier that year actually
was a series of several dozen geysers
and over the years we took bunches of
them this in fact was done in my
research group we just planned an entire
survey of the south polar terrain so we
could see what relationship these
geysers had to the surface features and
we in fact found that all these geysers
and there's all over a hundred of them
actually they're erupting from these
fractures in the form like Fisherville
volcanism you might see in Iceland so
this of course was very very exciting
and these geysers also form a plume if
you take an image like this and you
colorize it in the right way you
colorize that gray light the big the
faint gray levels gray light levels you
you get a plume so Cassini over its life
there's flown through this plume about a
dozen times and sampled it's the
composition of this plume so we know the
composition of the particles we know the
particles are accompanied by vapour okay
what do we know just jump to the chase
here we know that the vapor in the plume
is 90% water we know that there are
compounds like carbon dioxide ammonia
methane to the tune of one percent by
volume are you noticing hydrogen oxygen
carbon okay
we don't know what the mass 28 feature
is it could be any one of these
compounds we found light hydrocarbons
and we have evidence that there are
carbon hydrocarbons that are even larger
and we think those could be the parent
molecules the larger molecules of the
light species that we see we found that
the
the there's a sighs segregation the
bigger particles are near the surface
this is in the geysers and the bigger
particles are salty salt salinity
comparable to that of the earth's oceans
this tells us that the salt rich
particles originate as droplets from a
salty liquid reservoir and with time we
came to find evidence of silica
particles which we found silica
particles which is evidence that the
evidence for hydrothermal activity on
the seafloor so I hope you're getting
excited because because we were so this
the environment the kind of prototypical
environment we had in mind was a famous
hydrothermal field called lost City it
was the first so-called low temperature
thermal hydrothermal field there's only
ninety degrees C and this is what we
think we're looking at on the surface of
Titan Enceladus not the black smoker
types where the temperature is 500
degrees centigrade but ninety degrees
centigrade is more we're thinking these
are carbonate structures found at lost
city and we also know that the ocean now
is global I won't go into details here
but there's and it's thickest under the
South Pole so what we have found meets
all the requirements of a habitable zone
and this just shows you detail of the
what we think each fracture is what the
heat is formed by condensation the heat
emerges because of the condensation of
latent heat and you have geyser vapor
and particles the smaller ones that salt
free ones escape to form Saturn's
earring and so on lots of details I
could go into so this moon presents to
us the most promising place and all the
solar system at this point in time to
test our ideas about the origin of life
and to see whether or not life is
actually even arisen in in this place
and what approaches are we going to take
well we would carry on our next mission
we would carry mass spectrometers these
are instruments
that just can tell you across the
breadth of a spectrum in mass that is
from very light to heavy just what kind
of molecules are there we might be able
to ask the question do we have any amino
acids there are there any nucleic acids
there there fatty acids there some of
these substances can be produced without
biology so we need to really be careful
about our search we need to search for
other signatures we would target amino
acids and possibly other other
biomolecules to look for non abiotic
patterns and chirality and we have such
an instrument in fact as being developed
at UC Berkeley to do this and we could
look for I guess I this is a jumping
over this one but basically said this
already there we know that Enceladus
meets the formal requirements for a
habitable zone it's got all that it
takes but we want to know this and we
want to know is the ocean actually
inhabited and the thing about and sell
it is better than any other because we
know it now after 13 years of
investigation we understand it better
than any other candidate habitable zone
in the solar system so I have been
clamoring for a long time now
saying this is the place we need to go
so and there's a I don't have time
there's a whole lot of stuff that we
could do I just mentioned some of it we
could look for parent molecules we could
look for disequilibrium we could look
for a high temperature alteration that's
pretty simple you look for the isotopes
of a simple compound or a simple element
and the ratio of those isotopes can
often tell you about the temperature we
could see is the temperature hot enough
to get to yield enough chemical energy
for biology to exist we could look for
Biot biologically produced abundance
patterns I think I have a diagram here
abiotic meaning not by made by biology
if you look for at a type of molecule
like an amino acid going from the light
amino acids to the heavy if it was not
produced by biology it might look like
that the biology would have a particular
pattern and then if you had a different
biology you might have a different pad
so these are the kinds of things that we
might possibly do and then of course
we'd like to look for chirality and we
can do that again there are instruments
that can do it if we find really that
there's a predominant handedness in
anything that we sample and it really
was a strong handedness first of all we
know right away something's out of
equilibrium and it's creating that and
we don't know at least at this point
that there's any process that really
abiotic lis produces a strong chiral
signature so if we found something like
that that would be very suggestive of
life and then there's a whole bunch of
other things we could search for a
sufficient level of complexity and
molecular constituents I went through
that little spiel earlier about the
kinds of experiments that are being done
on computers to investigate the origin
of complexity but as I said we think
that life has done this too over
billions of years you could get things
as complex as you and I so we are trying
to think of the ways where you could
actually develop a metric to determine
if something that we find is complex
enough to signify that it was created by
life and then we could look for those
polyelectrolytes I told you that might
be diagnostic of life and one of my
favorites because there's always this
question of how confident will we be if
we ever find something we think is life
and we come forward and tell the world
we found life and then it's not right I
mean that would just be horrible so I
mean it would be worse than horrible but
horrible serves for right you know so we
want to be sure and I'm I'm the one
saying and a lot of people don't like
this I don't know why they don't like it
but I think the best thing to do is go
search for organisms I mean if I could
show you a video clip of an organism
that we picked up in the material that
we collected from the plume of Enceladus
and I show C and you can see it move and
you could see a bunch of them move and
and they're clearly alive and they're
clearly not just bits of dirt floating
around I mean that would be an
unambiguous sign that we
life it would tell you nothing about
biochemistry but we would know for sure
that it would have life I don't know why
you're laughing but anyway it's not
funny to me so anyway what kinds of
missions could we do we could do another
Saturn orbiter with multiple fly
throughs that's like doing a Cassini
mission smaller very focused with
instrumentation that was deliberately
designed to conduct the kind of
experiments I just described and look
for the kind of characteristics I've
just spent a long time telling you about
you could do better you could go into an
orbit around Enceladus and you could
continuously fly through the plume every
orbit you could collect a lot more
material that way and of course you
could land and let the stuff fall on you
I forgot to mention that 96% of the mass
that's coming out in these geysers the
solid mass is falling back down it's all
always snowing at the South Pole of
Enceladus
could it be snowing microbes on
Enceladus I mean like how cool would
that be
so anyway but I have to say after all is
said and done that the mission that I
would like most to see I won't see it
but maybe someday your children or
grandchildren might get to go visit in
the far future might go back to the
Saturn system and visit the Enceladus
interplanetary geyser park
in a spacecraft not unlike the Starship
Enterprise thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's talk about it let's talk okay we
go over here so what's this about this
starship Star Trek that came in kind of
the like snowing microbes there at the
end and then I pulled Star Trek yeah
yeah I got I that was my scene out of
the 2009 Star Trek I was a consultant on
the movie okay I met JJ Abrams at Ted I
think at the same Ted I met Kevin Kelly
a long time ago and he invited me to be
a consultant so that's I suggested that
I didn't get a penny for it by the way
but they used it they liked it I got to
see Chris Pine get the crap kicked out
of him I went to go I went to go see a
scene I wanted to go see a scene being
filmed on the bridge by the when I was
there in LA at the time it wasn't the
bridge it was the bar scene where the
young Captain Kirk gets into trouble and
gets beat up bar scene saw us have
fights it seems like so dr. Travis
Dirk's asks what would we do if we found
life anywhere else and what's sort of
the protocol that NASA is presumably
prepared for right now
they have no protocol well no not really
they're just getting to grips now with
what how we gonna go about doing it
because it's really like imminent you
know Carl Sagan used to say that you
know we were the generation that could
do this he was occurring to his
generation and we could really find life
well we could really really find life
that's to really
and so but you know I mean it when I say
we're just getting to grips now with how
we go about doing it because it's very
hard it's not like saying I want to go
look at the craters on you know a moon
around Uranus or something like that and
I'm just gonna carry a camera and I know
how to do that and I know how to study
craters we're still can't you tell we're
groping we're trying to figure out
what's the best way to do this we're
talking about the next missions yeah oh
yeah there's a group there's two groups
that are putting in a proposal to what's
called a new frontiers program at NASA
they're coming they're proposing to do a
mission back to and each proposing to do
a mission back to Enceladus with the
express purpose of searching for life
we've done a lot of other stuff at
Saturn and at Enceladus we don't have to
redo it we just have to find now if the
plume this obviously this accessible
habitable zone is if we can find life in
it so that's happening and I have to say
in the last two years a year and a half
I've been approached by no fewer than
five people over email claiming that
they knew people of high net-worth who
would be interested in funding a private
mission back to and so it is fire were
interested in getting involved or
something like that so there's a lot of
interest in doing this and I'm very
happy to see it but we're but I mean it
when I say we're just now getting to
grips with trying to figure out how
exactly to do it now we've been
screaming about it for ten years and it
finally something it takes that long to
win and then how long does it take to
get there and start discovering things
well like no I think the earliest launch
could be like 2025 or something like
that okay if we're thinking these are
the NASA generated missions the
proposals where we wouldn't get there
until 2035 2030 for something like that
to Enceladus so the 2035 could be
oh sorry big maybe or you could never
say no you can't prove a negative you
can't prove a negative
okay so just because we didn't find any
life wouldn't mean that life isn't there
it just meant that we didn't detect it
in the plume but it could be it just
depends it depends if life is there it
depends how large a signature is is is
it so feeble that it's wiped out its
signatures that we would detect remotely
or wiped out by not remotely but that we
would detect in the plume mmm or wiped
out by other abiotic signatures so you
know it just depends so Reid asks if we
find evidence of that how would we know
if it's similar to life here the way you
described it life as we know it or that
it's quite different what would the
indicators either way
well if we found we went searching for
amino acids and we found that it used
that the ones that were predominant you
know the abundance pattern looked like
at the abundance pattern that we have
here on earth
if they were chiral and as well I don't
think it had to be chiral in the same
way but if they were handed there was a
handedness if nucleic acids were the
same you know although all the modules
if all the modules of the abundance
different then would be just chemically
generated and life as we know it has an
abundance pattern you also suggested
there's other abundance patterns that
might show up there would not be a
signature of life as we know it but of
some others maybe maybe maybe I mean
they're amino acids the building blocks
of our kind of life are everywhere
there's amino acids and meteorites they
find precursor molecules to amino acids
in molecular clouds they're doing this
with radio telescopes they find that I
don't know if they found nucleic acids
in Astrophysical environments but I know
that they can irradiated with
ultraviolet radiation and produce the
nucleobases that way so they're common
there just has to physically common so
it could be that we find some
and this is an important point it could
be refined life on Enceladus that has
exactly the same biochemistry we have
but and here's an important point when
you talk about for example Mars maybe
even Europa the further out you go in
the solar system from Earth the very
much less a chance there is that there
has been an exchange of material so it's
not it's not out of the question we
could find on Enceladus an identical
biochemistry but it still is a second
Genesis because you couldn't get a
tardigrade for example like the heroes
of extremophiles you know you couldn't
get one of those all the way to
Enceladus that would be highly unlikely
so remain degree I don't know they're
just bitching little bugs man there they
can they they can shrivel up they can
last it seems for thousands of years
without water without they can live in
just extreme it's they're just amazing
in a weird sort of way yeah we're
talking about actual biology here it's
got to be weird right I guess so we
already have weird stuff here that's
who's gonna make it
so our TAS expectable question what do
you think the chances are finding local
life in a place like finding one finding
basically solar system source of life
versus the now in numerous exoplanets
that we're looking at at a vast distance
recovering not physically but other ways
well they don't have the benefit of ever
having the opportunity to go sample so
they have to do it all remotely and they
would you know I think they will spend a
lot of effort looking for things out of
the out of equilibrium excuse me like
oxygen that's a big one
you know if they found oxygen very much
out of equilibrium they might say you
know there's no well they they might say
there's no abiotic way that that could
happen so it must be biology but here's
here's the thing you know there's always
a downside there's always a way in which
it might not be the case first-first
there could possibly
we be a way that oxygen goes out of
equilibrium at the time we're looking at
the body maybe it's limited and it does
it may not signify life and and another
thing is that for a long period of time
of life on Earth like 2 billion years I
think it was about 2 billion years there
was no oxygen it was all there was no
photosynthesis had started but it really
didn't produce a lot of oxygen until
about 2 billion years had gone by so
we're talking about bugs yet life like I
said the gases of the early Earth would
still have been recognizable from the
distance being out of chemical
equilibrium wouldn't they I don't know
why don't you Jim but you would see you
wouldn't see yeah but then what did we
have we had methane we had ammonia I
mean we see things like that I don't
know I mean I don't know the answer to
your question things out of equilibrium
is definitely the kind of things they
would look for right right
but I I feel that we are in a very much
better situation because we will
actually sample it's nearby and we can
sample Kevin Kelly asks this is kind of
a long now question was what is the most
distant time accompli of completion of
the serta longest duration of any of our
current space exploration projects what
are the the ones that have you know sort
of a longest horizon to you um I don't
quite know do you mean like Voyager yeah
boy does not Voyager telling Joseph
Voyager well Roger was launched in 1977
the year that Star Wars came out okay
and it spent the 1980s crossing the
solar system and then it left the solar
system I mean it went beyond the
magnetic bubble of the Sun into the
interstellar medium
yes that'd make a good title of an album
now interesting so but it's and it's
still actually taking data I mean
because it's it's instruments on board
that measure the flux of charged
particles and magnetic fields it was
able to deduce that it had passed beyond
the magnetic influence of the Sun into
the interstellar medium so that
been going on since 1977 and it will go
on and will continue to go on it's there
a new one like you me well New Horizons
will continue to go on I don't know that
it'll keep Mary making measurements how
long do we expect to keep getting data
from the wager until it's it's
radioisotope you know electric
electricity generators die out and
there's no more power for it I forget it
could be another 20 years or on that
order I'm doing so is the Voyager story
being told and well yeah well this is
the 40th anniversary and so there's been
a lot of activity
remembering what Voyager was all about
because it really was I still say it was
the most iconic planetary mission we
have lives the Apollo 11 of the
planetary program there were other
missions that went before it there were
other missions that even went to the
outer solar system at least Jupiter and
Saturn before it but it it really showed
us what the outer solar system was like
and in doing that it opened up the
entire solar system to us because that's
where most of the mass in our solar
system is and then of course it turned
back and took a picture of the earth you
know the pale blue dot and then it
continued with a message from Earth and
it's now transformed us it's redefined
us into an interstellar species so it
really was it just resonated with people
the whole human adventure of it and
Homer's Odyssey
you know the 12 years across the solar
system so there's gonna be a documentary
about that and on August 23rd it's going
to appear on PBS and I'm proud to say
that it will be followed by a 20-minute
mini documentary which features yours
truly going in search of life and and
it's
and this digital preview of them no and
it's called second Genesis second that's
the name of it I thought there was a
very provocative title I hope it gets a
lot of people Andy we asked about this
chirality this left-handedness right
handedness is a life plausible that has
an opposite handedness to the oh yes
because we think it makes sense to me it
was just a statistical thing you know
the more erosion accident oh oh a frozen
accident is that the terminology yeah
okay good
somewhere along a line that just had to
be this and then there was two choices
you could go left it could go right in
one case it went down handed one but
life could have gone down why not
and then how would that life in our life
interact there those micronesia
microorganisms in our microorganisms
well that's that's interesting I wonder
if like one could eat the other I never
thought about them maybe maybe that's a
that's an interesting idea I don't know
probably eat but not made I suspect this
I don't know I haven't I haven't thought
that far looking for you
so you sort of started with the what if
life is not a bug better feature what if
life is not one-off but common and you
seem to be suggesting if we find just
one other instance then it's common yeah
one other instance of an independent
origin yes of an independent origin okay
yeah mmm see how that plays out what if
there's just two hmm what if there's
just two why would it be common how
could there be just two
would say more what there's so many
potential places where it could occur
that if there's two then that equals
many it's just you know it's like the
existence theorem being proven or
something like that it's like it's like
the spell being broken you can't say
anymore if you find one other instance
of it that I mean that just that seems
even more absurd than to say it's just
one I mean if it could happen if it's
not special you know really really
special then and to would would do it
really but think about it is there's all
the I've told you all them the basic
building blocks are a still physically
common I know they're everywhere so and
and we don't like thinking and I just
don't think it's possible
our Esther physical scientific
investigations tell us that you know
what's what we have here is everywhere
so if you know if we have the basic
building blocks here in our solar system
and we see them in other molecular
clouds across the galaxy and in other
solar systems then then the same things
happen I mean not in every case but
there's just so many many planets the
numbers are staggering it had to happen
more than once sounds like you would be
surprised if it turns out that it was it
is a one-off well we're never gonna know
so you know but I don't think I'm gonna
be part of the the made you see and you
know part of what Carl Sagan was
pointing at and you're pointing at it's
in this century we're gonna be looking
at some likely places nearby and we're
gonna do some pretty serious spectral
analysis of potentially atmospheres and
other distant exoplanets so we're
suddenly getting a lot more data to or
it's been speculation and modeling and
all of that for a long time now we're
getting serious data coming in and if it
small negative negative
kind of like SETI has been up to this
point the certain point you go for long
I know that that is that will be a
possibility but then you have to examine
did we really go about it the right way
I you know now there's a big infusion of
money to do SETI in a much bigger way to
keep the data and have it there to be
examined by very sophisticated
algorithms a lot of stuff they just
weren't able to do the first time around
because there wasn't any funding so now
we're finally we've got multiple targets
to go look and and reasons because we do
know like I didn't sell it as we know
the we know why this particular body
intrigues us we've only measured we know
the basic elements of there we even
think that the basic geochemical energy
requirements are being met so maybe
there's no life there at all but it's
really worth checking and and I think we
stand a chance if there is life there
finding it you've probably thought
through some of what happens then takes
the strongest case you you have
microorganisms ideally living ones
snowing down well they might not be
alive by that time but who cares I mean
they came alive or did there's
microorganisms and it's in the late
2030s ounds like we get there and we
discovered this then what happens we all
celebrate it's fun we celebrate but what
else do we do I mean I thinks one of
those big jobs it's like been you know
Hubble discovered there were other
galaxies and stuff like that suddenly
scalish totally who we are what we are
oh yeah all that stuff so you know go
cosmic here I think I'm gonna go cosmic
and I've thought of this I think
scientifically it would be just almost
cataclysmic I think that people would
get very excited about the topic we'd
have lots of missions to go and and you
know land on the surface really get
substantial samples
even maybe bring some back to earth that
would be a very very exciting day I
don't think that it would have as big of
an effect culturally hi I wanted well
because I just think people don't think
much of microbes microbes
microbes get happy right microbes get no
respect so it's not about our size and
caring so I I think I think that the
moment the moment that really would be a
cataclysm that you know and and it's
depicted in contact the movie contact
and in the book which is even better all
right is if we ever find an indisputable
signal from an intelligent organization
intelligent civilization I think that
would that would be what people really
have to come to grips with with with the
fact that we're not unique and there's
others out there that you know have
evolved to our state and and in fact if
we ever hear from another civilization
chances are excellent that they are well
beyond us if you just work out the
numbers like work through the Drake
Equation that's how it works out in
order for us to even here's signals from
someone else it means it means that they
are well advanced beyond us they've had
to they've had to learn things like how
to manipulate the energy of their star
in order to build their civilization
so there's regulation by some of the big
thinkers lately that we should not be
advertising where we are oh I have no
patience for that
so you haven't read the three-body
problem are you having didn't what the
book the three-body problem it's all
about seriously hostile but that sounds
like something that would be put out by
the NRA
[Applause]
seriously how paranoid can you get the
universe has been around for 13.8
billion years okay it's plenty of time
for four civilizations to be to live
long you know develop in advance if
that's what is possible if that's what
they do and I just think a they would
have been here by now if we were that
tantalizing and if we were that
interesting and B I think there's a
filter that only the organisms that
evolve to be a lot more benign and a lot
more a lot less violent and destructive
of each other than we are would be able
to amass that kind of effort to come to
knock on our door and do damage to us I
just think it's silly I think it's silly
I don't spend any time thinking of
extraterrestrial contact in that sense
like they come here and they probe and
they don't worry about that I think
we'll end there that's
[Applause]
[Music]